- Everything that I learned
in the Navy is not built
for this game at all.
(upbeat music)
My name is Jonathan Dock Farrow,
I was a Corpsman in the United States Navy
serving with the United
States Marine Corps.
- I am Lisa. I was an
Intelligence Specialist.
- I was a medic, the guy who
patched you up if you got shot.
- I served in Virginia Beach, Bahrain
and on the USS Bonhomme Richard.
- The last time that I played Battleship,
we'll say 25 years ago.
- 1984 was the last time
I played, nope, 1986.
- I'm gonna won, simply because I'm Doc.
- I was actually stationed on a ship,
so I think I'm gonna kick his ass.
(dramatic music)
- [Jonathan] Great.
- Let's do it.
- [Jonathan] You'll never
think to shoot me there.
- Somebody's gonna lose his fleet.
- This is not strategically
how a carrier group
would be by the way.
- And you know this how?
- [Jonathan] Well, how would you know?
- I was on an amphibious
assault ship. Ready?
(laughing)
B2.
- [Jonathan] Direct hit.
- (claps) Yes! (laughs)
- D4.
- Miss. As I suspected.
- [Jonathan] I'm sorry what was that?
- Hit.
- Direct hit, okay, great.
- [Lisa] Direct hit.
- Sweet.
I'm chasing after ya. I'm adjusting fire.
- D2, I'm already gonna put it in there.
- D2.
- [Lisa] Yes.
- It's my shot, right?
- Time's a wasting.
- [Jonathan] Okay.
(laughing)
F8.
- Miss.
- I'm sorry.
- [Lisa] E2.
- You sank my battleship.
(beeping)
(Lisa laughing)
- [Jonathan] Oh, it's funny?
- Pruned your ass.
You got your (beep) together now?
- My (beep) always been together.
I don't know what you're talking about.
- You sunk my patrol boat!
(beeping)
- [Jonathan] That's right.
- Miss.
D5.
- Hit.
- (claps) Yes.
Miss.
- Miss.
- God bless America.
- You're going down, you're going down.
- You sank my destroyer.
(beeping)
- How you feeling?
- Dying over here.
- Starting to sweat a little bit.
(Lisa laughing)
- I sweat all the time,
shut up.
- Hit.
(Jonathan laughing)
I wasted a missile.
- [Jonathan] I know, I know.
- I don't remember this being
so stressful when I was 12.
- Really? It is stressful.
- G8. I sunk your battleship!
(beeping)
- No! You sunk my courier!
- It's a courier.
- Hey!
- Is he bringing packages to your ship?
- Ha! I just sunk some
(beep) right there, didn't I?
- You got a direct hit.
- And I know where the next one's going.
- [Lisa] No sinking is
gonna be done right now.
- And guess who's gonna be saying
they sunk some (beep) next?
- [Lisa] No! You sunk my battleship!
- I didn't sink your
battleship! I sank your courier!
- You didn't sink my courier.
- Your carrier.
- I sunk your patrol boat.
- You didn't shoot my patrol boat.
- Destroyer. U Boat?
- We didn't have U Boats.
- All right, we could be in 1940.
- [Jonathan] The Germans had, oh, my God.
(Lisa laughing)
- I'm so excited.
(laughing)
(shouting)
- What happened? What'd I say?
- You sunk my destroyer.
- [Jonathan] That's right I
sunk your god damn destroyer!
- Good strategy takes time.
- You're getting bombed,
you don't have time.
- E8.
- Yes.
J9.
(shouting)
(beeping)
- [Jonathan] Yes!
(laughing)
- You sunk my whole fleet.
I went in there with a good game plan
of putting the ships in the pegs.
We came out victorious.